Sure. That's your transition to
the new platform when the time
is right is going to be as
smooth as possible. Really nice
to meet you today and I'm just
going to echo what Ankit said,
really grateful for for your
feedback so far and and the
upcoming one today as well.
No problem. Yeah. So I'm. I'm an
information scientist advisor.
Um, I sit in the, uh, what's
called the WDM group, so we're
worldwide research, development
and medical. Um, the part that I
mainly support is research and
development. So.
A lot of my use of um of the
platform is to do with our very
looking at information regarding
our very early portfolio
decisions. And I mean when I say
early I mean kind of phase two,
phase one decisions that that go
no goes on those projects and
looking at the information in
terms of competitors the kinds
of areas of.
The target areas, the indication
areas, um, looking at um.
What's ahead as well? What's?
What's uh, what's kind of?
Being developed ahead of us. So
and I'm sure as a lot of other
pharmaceutical companies our
goal is to be um first in class
or if not first in class at
least best in class. So it's
looking at, it's looking at that
information really.
So yeah.
Right. That's really useful.
Thank you for that, bilinda. No
problem.
Great. Um, I think we are good
to go with the demo then.
Let me just share my screen and
I'll switch my camera off to um
to minimize the distraction for.
Um, from when I'm presenting. So
just a refresher, Belinda. This
is where um.
You can see my screen right? Yes
I see it, yes right. So this is
where you can access our new
platform the through the beta
button that you have available
on the once you.
Once you look in um as the
pop-up window shows, you can
access it through that link.
So.
Since you have lost tested with
us, we have added a list of
saved reports here to the bottom
left corner. Last time when you
when you were testing for us,
Belinda, this was just a
placeholder. Right now you can
access and this. As you can see
I've got a few examples here.
Um, you're recently saved
reports in the in the order of
newest at the top. We also have
this icon here at the top.
Top right that you are able to
click through and access your
saved reports if you are
anywhere else then the landing
page.
Um, and then the create new
report button. We made it bigger
to make sure that it's easily
visible and accessible to
everyone. Um to just be able to
click through and create a new
analysis from from scratch. Some
of these are still placeholders
as you are aware, but we are
still working on those.
Um to umm to make sure that we
include them in the in the next
releases. So a short summary of
what has been added to the
landing page.
Any faults? Any feedback on
this?
No, that's good. That's good. I
mean, uh.
It's good to have that great
port report up.
Up front and centre and and the
recently saved ones as well.
For sure.
Yeah.
Right. OK.
Good. Great to hear that. Thank
you.
OK, so let's create a new
report. Um. So as we press, uh,
that button, then we get the UM.
The window here and um this list
mind you is is slightly
shortened than it will be when
we are finished with the
product. But you can see there
are different um starting points
for your report that you can
choose from. So let's go with
indications. You did mention
that sometimes this is how you
run your analysis. So if we
click create reports then a
report with default and
previously added pre added
columns.
Um, pops up on your page. You
can then able to.
You are then able to manipulate
it further so as we go through
the, uh, manage columns here.
You can see these are the
columns that we have preselected
for you. Um, it's 20 in total.
And then on the left hand side
we have grouped our data points
into different categories for
you to be able to um add
anything else that you find that
you may find useful.
You have a search bar here, so
whatever you type in here.
Let's go with date um, all of
the.
All of the data points that
contain that phrase.
Across all of those folders are
going to pop up. Here you can
see we have already couple of
date fields selected as well.
And then you can also expand
each of those folders and just
search within that folder to
find whatever you need and you
can see that the each of those
folders have also been um.
Segmented um with the UM with
relevant data points under
different categories as well to
to make them easier to find
hopefully.
So I do appreciate it was a lot
of information. Um.
I'm going to stop here for a
second for any questions Belinda
you might have may have or any
pointers for us maybe.
No, it looks good. It looks a
lot simpler than the previous
two step.
Process. And I'm assuming, um,
with the active columns that you
just can, uh, drag and drop to
change order. Is that right?
Yes, that's exactly right. Yes.
OK yeah, good to know.
So let me just show you.
Because last time I think when
you tested that option wasn't
really that visible. So at right
now you can drag and you can see
where that column is going to um
to land when you drop it. So um,
we've added that a little bit of
shading.
Um, on here as well. Yeah,
that's very clear. That's good.
That's good. And uh, what do you
how do you choose what you sort
the column by?
When I saw the actual report.
Sorry, yeah.
What I sort the column. Ohh OK,
so that's the that's on the
report itself. So let me just
show you um.
But before we do that, let me
just show this little button.
Uh, this little red button here
also allows you to quickly
remove columns that you may not
find useful.
So cool, let's apply changes.
And here is the report and then
as you hover over those columns
you can see the three dot menu.
So this is where you do your
sorting and your filtering. OK
so.
This is an example, but it's a.
It's a text column field, so um.
You can either select from a
dropdown list or search, or do
both so you can mix and match
your filtering however you find
um, however you find useful, so
we can select.
A few things here. And then if
we want to include all of the
sodium compounds as well, then
we can also do that.
So let's apply filters.
And then this is the, these are
our results for now. Just a
little disclaimer, obviously not
all of that data that we have
available on evaluate platform
has been migrated to the new
platform yet. Some of these are
just placeholders just to give
you an idea what it will look
like. So if something doesn't
look right in terms of the data,
this is the that's the reason.
So no, it makes sense. It makes
sense. That's good. So yeah,
it's a lot easier to sort
through the. In the old report,
sorting was very complicated,
I've found.
But uh, yeah, this is very, this
is very useful because uh, quite
often with the, when we're
looking at information, it's
it's great to be able to uh,
slice and dice it by certain
categories. So for instance
small versus large molecules and
in a particular indication. So
yeah, that's really good.
Right, that's really useful
feedback. Thank you. Um, just
another function that I wanted
to show you. We also added the
umm pin column to the left
option. So now you can see the
generic name column is on your
left hand side and as we scroll
our report to the right to get
to the columns further down, you
can see what data they actually
correspond to.
Yeah, which is a new feature.
And then in terms of filtering.
There is a slightly different
option for filtering your
numerical fields so that applies
to all of the accounts or um
sales fields as well. So if we
click through show filters,
these are the options that you
have. So a little bit of a
functionality that's.
Similar to Excel without having
to export your report.
So we can do less than let's go
20.
They filter.
And you only get your.
Relevant information here.
So that's the numerical filter
and then slightly different
filter options for your date
fields. Also sort sorting is
available on all tile types of
fields as well, so you can see
for dates you can select from a
specific date or to or within a
range as well. OK.
Is that something you would find
useful? Yes, definitely,
definitely. I mean particularly
the date ones I think would be.
It would be very useful in that.
Um, in terms of what? Is it just
the generic name that you can
pin to the left, or can you
choose what you pin on that left
hand side?
You can choose any other column.
All of those have that
functionality. So yeah, whatever
is is um is relevant for you at
the time.
OK, great. That's good to know.
Right. OK. Ohh it. Just a quick
question in terms of the date
field, as you can see you can
filter on a specific as go as
granular as a day level. Is that
something that you would find
useful or would you go maybe a
high slightly less granular and
let's say I don't know a month
and a year. Yeah, it's it's
always useful to see the
granular day. I think one
probably when I come to kind of
filtering.
It maybe wouldn't be quite as
granular. It would be more
likely to be at the most a month
than a year, more likely just a
year. But um, it's it's always
good to see the granular date
though.
OK, understood.
Alright so this is the the
reports upgrade that we have
done recently. As you can see we
can save every single report
that we have been working with.
You can also download it with
into uh.
CSV or Excel file as well, yeah
um and we can click here and you
can see our newly created report
is on on our list here.
Um, so that's what we have added
and then let's go back to the to
the landing page. So um search
we still working on, but we will
definitely let you know when
that's available through the
menu button we can go to
different um different data
points where you can start your
analysis from. So all of not
all, some of them are still
placeholders but we can click
through.
Drugs here.
And then here you can see the
top level KPIs that we have for
the entirety of evaluate
universe that we cover when it
comes to drugs.
Latest events again, uh,
placeholders at the moment, and
then the top of the selected
classifications as well. And as
we Scroll down, we also have an
embedded report that you can
also edit in the same way as the
one that we have just created or
saved if you want to have it at
hand whenever you whenever you
log in.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's good. That's good
to have still have those
embedded reports because I did
used to use those quite a lot.
When I wasn't really sure where
to start maybe or what category
to pick to get to the topics I
wanted. I looked down the menu
list and you quite often have
some reports prepopulated that I
could go and edit. So that's
always useful to see.
From my point of view, but then
saying that they're creating the
reports you've made that much
easier that I'm. I'm sure I will
find it easier to find the
topics that I need.
Right. Really glad to hear that.
Umm, so this is what we have.
Some of these are placeholders,
but we are also thinking about,
you know, having here a chart to
summarize whatever we are on
the, uh, currently on the page.
So in this instance, we would
have a summary of drug sales
within a specific date range,
like here for example. So a bar
chart, is that something that
you would find useful or is it
not necessarily needed for your
analysis?
Um.
It depends what you're going to
visually put on there. Sales,
not so much for from my point of
view, but I'm sure there would
be others that would find the
sales interesting. But if say
for instance, there's a number
of drugs in development in phase
three phase in different phases
on on the various bits, but uh,
yeah.
That that could be interesting
to me.
OK, that's useful to know. Um,
so.
It hasn't been built yet. So
those KPIs are placeholders at
the moment. But the idea of the
new platform is for you to be
able to click through and go
more granular with your
analysis. Yeah, so as I said,
this is the high level
everything in terms of evaluate
coverage in terms of numbers.
But in future if you were able
to, let's say click through
here, phase two, you did say
that you focus mostly on phase
two, phase one and earlier
drugs.
Would that be useful to then
take you to a similar looking
page but all of these?
Would be only relevant to phase
two drugs? Yes, definitely,
definitely.
Right, that's really useful to
know.
OK. Let me just show you and let
me just filter quickly on a drug
that might give us some.
Data here so.
We have also added recently a A
click through option through the
generic name to take us to the.
Product Um item page so this
just to give you an idea I do
appreciate it's not you know
related to face the drugs but
this is just to give you an idea
what it would look like it
obviously you know changed all
of that information only applies
to to the product now so.
You've got the sales, you've got
number you, you will have number
of of different um. Well that's
the highest faced, OK. So you
will have.
Um. Number of different products
related to a generic name at
different stages of development?
Um. And then all of the
companies involved in the in the
product and so on so.
Is that something that you would
find useful? Potentially, yes,
definitely. I'm assuming. I'm
assuming that the number of
drugs by ice phase, I'm assuming
that would be.
Particularly if it was looking
at uh, different uh indications.
So I know sometimes you have you
can have like a monoclonal
that's been developed for um
arthritis type indications
versus cancer indications
because I can see that the one
for this one's quite a general
one, isn't it a general cancer
indication. So is is that what
I'm am I assuming that correctly
for that number of drugs by
highest phase part on there?
So that's yes, that's that's a
good point. So if it was an
indication page, this is what
you would be able to see a
number of drugs, different
stages of development for a
particular indication therapy
area and so on and so on. Yeah,
this is just to give you an idea
what it would look like. And
then you know let's say we are
on the breast cancer page, then
you click through phase two,
phase one and that takes you to
phase one breast cancer and then
yeah and then this is even more
granular in terms of the.
Of where you want to, where you
want to go potentially. Yeah.
Yeah. Got it. Sounds good. Yeah.
Right. Um, I think that's
everything I wanted to cover
today. Ankit, is there anything
that um?
That we still wanted to discuss
today.
Um, no, I think I think it was,
yeah, fairly short just because
of, um, the previous tests that
Belinda's done. So, um, I'm just
trying to think if there's
anything else maybe with regards
to those designs that we've got
for visualizations. So I know,
Belinda, you mentioned that they
not all charts would be helpful,
but for the ones that you are
looking at, maybe if you could
give us some feedback on some of
the designs that we've got.
That'd be helpful.
Ohh.
That is true. That's a good
point actually. Um, let me just
open it and I will re share my
screen.
Because there's potentially
those um.
I think that was the, was it the
top five, top ten that we could
drill into as well. We've got
some designs for that, so be
good to get Belinda's thoughts
on it.
Yes, definitely. It's always
better to.
To show, but yes as I'm Keith
said designs at the moment so
things can change here, but
Linda um, this is what we are
thinking in terms of um.
What's the high level indication
page would look like? You can
see there is a graph at the
bottom that you can change the
view of as well.
Umm.
And then, um, that's not the.
Thick matutu?
Those nodes.
About this was the one, so then
there is also another one with
the high level KPI's Ankit maybe
you've got it open, I can't seem
to find it at the moment.
Don't, but I can get it.
But just let me try again.
Linda, do you ever access any of
these, this kind of data on a
remote device or do you ever
have the need for it?
On a remote device? No, not
really, just because of my own
working situation. Now that's
not to say that people other
people wouldn't within the
company, but from my own working
situation though, I don't really
need to, OK?
It's helpful to know, ma'am. I'm
just gonna send you the link for
this other one.
I think it's opening, but it's
very slow today. Apologies.
That's OK. I think. I think it
is generally, I've just been on
another call and the whole
system has been really slow too.
So maybe not just you guys,
because Monday isn't it exactly.
OK. Thank you. I think I've.
Have you got it?
I've been having issues with.
Access today. But why? Why? Why?
It's opening, so we're with.
Umm.
No, that's the same one that
I've opened earlier.
Umm.
Bear with me, ohh sorry. Got it
now.
Sorry, Belinda. OK, apologies.
OK, so this is it and this is
the.
Level 2 indication, so a little
data map here that shows you
where you are when it comes to
evaluate indication tree. So you
can go more granular within that
indication or if you want to
look at the whole.
Blood, then that's also an
option, um. And then of course,
as we mentioned, you know, the
uh, number of drugs, different
stages of development, um,
depending on um.
On the indication as well. And
then also the idea is for you to
be able to manipulate your um
sales um prediction to show only
your the the time range that's
relevant to yourself.
And then the KPI so the the the
top drugs um as well.
And then you can also filter and
show slightly more or less
however you want to um. However
you want to look at the UM.
At different um.
Uh, at different um
classifications within the
within that indication as well.
So then an uncle, please correct
me if I'm wrong. Once you do
that, your report also filters
on whatever is relevant here.
Ohh no, sorry, apologies. It's
the idea is for this to be the
reverse. So as you manipulate
your report here, then the high
level analysis also shows
whatever you're interested in,
whatever you've filtered your
report on. OK, so that's the,
that's the thinking. So. So it
was the other way around, yes,
same with the index page as
well. So.
Back to first showed you, when
you go in and you sort of see
the calculated metrics and you
see the events and your top
three. So the idea is as you
sort of manipulate your data via
managed columns or filters, um
all of your metrics and all the
information sort of the top half
will then update.
Exactly. All right. Got. Yeah.
Yeah, that's useful. That is
really useful.
To uh say and to know.
That it is doing that.
Because that.
Yeah. So it's it's some
something that sometimes you
have to, you have to dig deep
into the report to find it,
don't you? So to have it there,
up there in front, in front of
you is, is, is great. Yeah, very
useful.
Oh, and do you export much to do
you would you normally
manipulate your data then yeah,
sort it out or do you kind of
just yes, because I'm sharing
with a number of people and to
be honest, it's the easiest way
to share.
Cool. So should we maybe just
show? So at the minute, what
we've basically built is the
ability to export and it'll just
export the data as it is.
There's no, none of the fancy,
sort of.
There's none of the fancy
options to sort of include data
definitions etc, but maybe if we
can. We've obviously built the
basic functionality of
exporting, but is there any
other requirements that you'd
have with regards to exporting?
I mean, you've got this, the CSV
and the Excel formats at the
moment I guess if.
Um, I mean, I can take
screenshots of some of the
visualizations if if need be,
but I don't know if there's sort
of an option maybe to do like a
PDF type.
Export of visualization when
you've put the.
Details in that you that it's
important to you for that
particular report and just just
as a thought just as an idea,
but I mean it's it's not the end
of the world if it if it can't
be because the the important
thing for us would be to get the
raw data out in in in the Excel.
OK, cool. Is that something that
you use in the current platform
exporting to PDF?
Uh, yes, sometimes. Sometimes.
Sometimes, sometimes the
visualizations are great for
when you're just for quickly
seeing.
Um, the data in over time like
you were showing um for for
someone else to be able to see
that kind of change over time in
as a visual reference. Yeah. OK
cool. And the final question
from me um this one came
directly from our product owner
is so these index pages that you
see. So if you scroll a little
bit down magnet you could see
that they're based around the
generic name so you can click
into the generic name.
You could get taken to a
separate page.
Is that how you'd expect it?
Would you expect it to be based
around the generic name, or
would you expect it to be around
based around the product itself?
Uh, what do you mean the actual
brand name? Yeah, the trade
name. No, I'd expect generic
name. I'd expect generic name.
Yeah, that's helpful to know.
Yeah. OK, cool. I think I'm out
of questions. That's been super,
super helpful. And I know we
have some time to spare as well.
Was there anything else that
you'd like to add, Belinda?
No, no, it's it's uh, it looks
like it's coming on really well.
Looking forward to when we can
use it.
For sure.
So I think I think it would make
a huge difference.
That's really good to hear. Um,
we'll pass on all the feedback
to the team. And then as as
always, I mean you're pretty
familiar with the process, we'll
look at all of the customer
feedback. We'll then analyze it,
assess it, summarize it. We'll
come back to you in the sort of
next few weeks and we'll let you
know exactly what all other
customers have said and how
we're going to kind of address
that moving forwards. I will
follow up the call with an
e-mail like I always do, just
some instructions on how to test
yourself and so if you can go in
the platform and test yourself.
I know you have done previously.
That would also be very helpful.
Um, there is a couple of
options. When you go into the
platform, you can either
complete a survey so you're
again familiar with that. That's
got around 15 to 20 questions on
specific features. But there's
also an option just to give
feedback. So if you didn't want
to go through the whole survey,
but you've picked up specific
things and then just choose the
give feedback option and then
you could literally just type
what you want and press submit
so you don't have to go through
the whole survey.
Um, but yeah, I'll follow up in
e-mail. So it'll, it'll be sort
of all clear in the e-mail. But
yeah, if there's, if there's
nothing else, we will. We'll
close the call for now and we'll
be sure to reach out next time
we're ready for some more
testing.
Sounds good. Thank you very
much. Cool. Perfect. Well, hope
you enjoy the rest of your day.
Alright. Yes, you too. Thank
you, Belinda. Bye bye.